[Music]
Ground Zero and the fight over
transgender bathroom is this diet town
in southern Virginia the unlikely faith
at the center of it all Gavin Graham
when you realize you're trans you
actually went to the doctor I went to a
gender therapist who specialized in
seeing transgender youth and it was very
apparent to her very quickly that
transition had to be done as quickly as
we possibly could because I was
suffering greatly you and your mom went
to school when you're a sophomore you
explained to the school what was going
on and my understanding is your high
school was pretty accepting and
receptive is that accurate I was assured
that I would be respected to school I
would be called exclusively Gavin and
exclusively by male pronouns at
Gloucester high school Gavin initially
used the bathroom in the nurse's office
but it was inconvenient to get to from
his classes and since he was already
using the men's room at restaurants and
movie theaters he asked the principal if
he could do the same at school the
principal agreed and Gavin says he used
the boys room without incident for
nearly two months for me it was a matter
of going in and going out and minding my
own business as most everyone does in a
bathroom but then the school board got
involved the school board ruled Gavin
could no longer use the men's room
instead they gave him the option to use
three unisex bathrooms something Gavin
wasn't interested in the problem is I'm
not looking for a compromise I'm not
looking for separate-but-equal I'm
looking for the same opportunities that
my peers enjoy every single day and that
includes using the same restroom as any
other student when you first learned
your case was going to be heard before
the Supreme Court what was your reaction
the Supreme Court aspect of it is
daunting if only because it's the
Supreme Court I mean this could go
really well or it could go really wrong
and I have to be prepared for that
reality but regardless of what happens
and will justify the means because even
if we suffer a law in we've generated a
conversation that moves the nation in
the right direction and if we win and
it's after I graduate I'm still doing
good for a lot of other kids
[Music]